if you're looking for the lowdown on the
fifth Rambo film you're in the right
place before you head out to see Sly
Stallone lay waste to some bad guys
again here's everything you need to know
about what the soldier is up to in Rambo
last blood remember he'll give you a war
you won't believe well the Rambo series
is definitely one of Stallone's babies
there are still a lot of other people
helping to bring the latest story to
life
Adrian grünberg is in the director's
chair for last blood it's only his
second feature film as director
following the 2012 Mel Gibson vehicle
get the gringo
however Grunberg has served as an
assistant director or second unit
director on several films since the 90s
including Apocalypto jarhead man on fire
and The Legend of Zorro last Blood
Screenplay is credited to Matthew Cyril
NIC like grunberg the writer doesn't
have a ton of credits to his name his
most high-profile credit to date is as
creator of the Amazon series abstention
unsurprisingly Stallone also had a hand
in writing the film David Morel receives
the standard based on characters by
credit for his 1972 novel first blood
though the author has clarified that
he's had no involvement with the Rambo
film since the first three we'll be able
to see what happens in the new one when
it hits theaters on September 19th 2019
Rambo has evolved quite a bit over the
decades what started as a somewhat quiet
psychological exploration of the effects
of war has turned into a massive
spectacle of revenge and blood-soaked
slaughter as the films have progressed
last blood will continue to ratchet up
the body counts when John Rambo takes on
a violent Mexican cartel reportedly the
movie's plot will feature John Rambo as
a ranch hand in Arizona struggling with
PTSD and keep him busy by taking on jobs
he learns that the daughter of a
longtime friend has been kidnapped while
partying in Mexico and he crosses the
border to rescue her he teams with a
journalist who is investigating a series
of kidnappings and the two uncover a sex
trafficking ring run by a drug cartel
naturally Pia then goes Rambo on
everyone involved from the look of
things last Blood will feature a
slightly different tone than the series
has featured in the last few entries for
starters it seems like they are dealing
with the fact that Stallone is in his
70s in a smart way John Rambo looks to
be going back to his roots
bit with his tactics the trailer shows
off a series of traps that the wily
soldier has set up to fight off his
enemies utilizing the same guerrilla
tactics he used back in his heyday it
also looks to be leaning into the
Western motif with an epic trailer remix
of Old Town Road inexplicably playing
throughout you really can't get away
from that song interestingly Rambo last
blood looks to have little to do with
previous entries in the series the film
has been compared to Logan the
definitive Wolverine movie showing what
happens when a pop-culture hero stops
adventuring so much as he nears the end
of his life going along with this theme
there aren't many returning characters
from previous Rambo films in this fifth
entry it makes sense 2008 s Rambo is set
in Burma halfway across the world from
the American Southwest and Mexico
settings of last Blood obviously the one
common thread here is John Rambo himself
Sylvester Stallone like Logan it appears
that Stallone's character is still
struggling with his past the things he's
experienced as well as the things he's
done and this looks to be a chance for
him to silence some of his inner
torments the story surrounding the war
veteran has evolved throughout the film
series so will be interesting to see
what last blood adds to the backstory of
John Rambo almost all of the cast of
Rambo last blood is new to the franchise
but one in particular we need to point
out is Sergio Parisse meant Chetta who
will play Hugo Martinez in the film also
known as at least one of the movie's
villains the character has been
described as the leader of the cartel
that Rambo crosses paths with and it
looks like he will make the hero go
through hell and back to win the day the
Madrid born policeman Chetta is more
well-known to Spanish audiences than
American ones but American viewers might
recognize him from Resident Evil
afterlife the movie life itself and the
FX series snowfall there are plenty of
other strong actors who will appear
alongside Sly Stallone and Rambo last
blood paz vega will play carmen delgado
the journalist who teams up with rambo
to track down the kidnapping victims you
might have seen her before in projects
like the oay and Spanglish some of the
other big names that stand out include
Oscar Hinata
from the losers the shallows and Pirates
of the Caribbean on Stranger Tides and
Louis Mandalore from My Big Fat Greek
Wedding finally one other cast member
were really excited about is Adriana
Barraza previously seen in movies
bable for and drag me to hell if you
come late to the Rambo game you may not
understand the significance of the title
last blood it works in a few different
ways but the most obvious is what ties
it back to the original film but the
time has come to face my past the first
film didn't even have Rambo and the
title instead like the novel it's based
on simply being titled first blood the
second film added the character's name
bringing us Rambo First Blood Part two
so it seems like this latest release is
trying to tie itself more to the tone of
the original two films and the more
over-the-top styles of the third and
fourth movies it could also signal that
this is Stallone's Lascaux is John Rambo
on the other hand it seemed unlikely
that a fifth film whatever happened and
Stallone has said he'd be glad to
reprise the role if last blood is
successful so I don't take that title
too literally new blood anyone check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]